Hey Youtubers it's Charlie the moment is finally
here we have Constantine footage for arrow
next week so is gonna be a breakdown of that
as well as the Q&A from flash and arrow this
week is the first Constantine on arrow what
does this mean for the future of the character
and what is this mean for the larger DC TV
universe when Matt Ryan was hired to come
on arrow this year it was just the deal for
this one episode it inside a multi-episode
deal but he could come back that Ryan is totally
happy to play the character again is a totally
awesome dude he's actually starting a play
on Broadway with Keira Knightley and he's
filming a movie soon so I don't know how long
it's going to be before he comes back but
be because they were able to make this deal
I think it means that they'll be able to make
deals like this in the future the deal itself
was only for Matt Ryan though so none of the
other Constantine characters are going to
come on but he might tell some jokes about
his friends from air quotes back home the
time is short so he's mostly being brought
on to bind Sara's soul back to her body that
is the whole deal that she doesn't have a
soul right now Matt Ryan was asked what's
different about this version of Constantine
than the version that he did on the NBC show
he said is essentially the same character
same outfit that is doing a couple things
that he did not do on the NBC show it's a
little more spectacular like I mean if if
you bring a character this big on arrow of
course are going to have some fun with them
he did say some specific things about the
action sequences but all this I'll leave that
for Wednesday just in the interest of not
spoiling things but just in terms of the future
of the Constantine TV show I'm not expecting
that to go to CW anytime soon they already
have problems fitting all the shows that they
bought into their schedule right now legends
of tomorrow presents a bit of a problem for
them because their spring schedule is already
full so in order to air legends of tomorrow
the connect to push one of their other shows
already so I don't think you have room for
Constantine right now but he's a big DC character
so there's always going to be reboots down
the road so like there at some point there
will be another Constantine TV show but for
the time being what I think that they'll do
is just try to use them in the CW shows the
next logical step would be to use them in
legends of tomorrow and like a big blockbuster
episode that that the big summer disaster
movie version of these DC TV shows doing fewer
episodes the spending a little bit more money
on each one so they were bring Constantine
on he could do crazier and crazier stuff than
he could ever do on a small budget but if
you're still confused about what's going on
there is no Constantine TV show in the works
at CW like that there's no talks going on
about that and this is just a one-off deal
for now but the writers will bring anyone
on the DC will let them ring on the people
asked him can you bring Batman on the show
the like we would love to bring Batman on
if Warner Bros. DC would lead us so yet you
will definitely see Constantine on flash and
arrow after this week but maybe not till next
season so on a Q&A territory just careful
for spoilers from flash and arrow this past
week if you haven't seen the episode yet in
their actually there weren't that many questions
from the flash mostly just people wanting
to see King shark fight other big CG villains
from DC the hearing our Christian Bernard
asks imagine King shark versus Grodd.
King shark hands-down the biggest WTF in my
book the season is so exciting yet King shark
versus drop would be amazing and they are
bringing brought on pretty soon but I don't
I don't really know what their budget allows
for in terms of CG fights if you member lassies
and whatever Grodd came on and the flash bottom
they were portions where it was grant Gustin
interacting with the green screen device and
they were fully CG scenes where it was like
grant Gustin fighting Grodd at superspeed
that that's when they go full CG flash always
feel like their level of special-effects is
good enough so that if you don't use it too
much and you don't do faces and close up looks
perfect is totally good next question fab
Robin asked about Francine son was Daniel
West the new 52 zoom yet the flash TV show
tends to blend a lot of different runs in
the comics the Wally West of the Earth one
like that I irises brother she was talking
about in the episode will be Wally West he
will become kid flash it is certain point
you remember even before the new 52 there
are a couple different iterations of Wally
West you have the first version who became
kid flash you were like the red costume to
look just like Barry Allen's and he started
wearing the yellow costume then after a crisis
on infinite earths he started wearing the
red costume again after he took the mantle
from Barry Allen became like full-blown flash
so because they're going with the character
that looks like the new 52 version of Wally
West the the African-American Wally West I
have no idea what his costume might look like
it is certain point no idea when he's gonna
get flash powers but he will be kid flash
first then it says nothing about what's going
on on earth two I'm talking about Earth one
Wally West next question Bradley S will Ronnie
be back yet he will deftly be that Robbie
Amell will come back on the show but we don't
know what form is gonna take the producers
said flat out that are version of Ronnie died
whatever they were closing the wormhole so
we see Robbie Amell again it will either be
a flashback or will be the earth two Ronnie
on arrow questions or go Wilford as could
you talk about how much all of her of the
CW universe could look like all of her of
the comics is there any chance of him becoming
the comical long-haired with the goatee husband
of black canary all over we all know from
the comics what I don't know how close so
get to all of her of the classic comics is
the least change iterations whenever they
rebooted the comics of post convergence I
haven't been reading green arrow site I don't
know how they change the character again he
is sporting more facial hair right now but
I'd I don't know if he'll go full all of her
beard and I don't think that his actual here
like on that on top of his head will ever
get any longer than it is right now the physical
appearance any side his actual character is
getting a little bit more laid-back a little
bit more used to the team little bit more
humorous little bit closer to his just asleep
persona now in terms of his relationship with
black canary I don't see his relationship
with Laurel changing anytime soon on the show
one of the problems with having like to two
characters on a team have sex with each other
is that he can pull the show towards melodrama
when it's really meant to be more of a crime
drama next question Martin asks how was a
possible that all of her never wins fights
anymore I'd I think it's because he's too
trusting of people catch them off guard like
as if he's fully prepared know that there's
no way you're going to beat them putting a
lot of people were upset with the last episode
with the quickness with which lady cop was
able to dispatch him one of the problems with
filming stuff like that is that they they
might've written in a certain way and the
page to make it look like she got the upper
hand on all of her in a dirty way and when
they film it that doesn't really come across
so just think of her is fighting dirty catching
all of her offguard and she did Jan that night
into his spine so he was completely immobilized
like no no matter how strong he was he would
have been able to do anything that moment
really wasn't about to fight it all is really
just getting her character to jump over that
moral hurtled to to realize okay I'm a human
being I'm not a terrible person will turn
myself in so that's what they were going for
but it just it may not have come across the
way it was filmed think everyone is many questions
on the videos this week though and it is you
do want me to use your question in a Q&A be
sure to use Jeopardy rules and and Frazier
comment in the formal question congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner the reverse
flash ring astrophysics 43 just be sure to
private message me on the back and my channels
and get your contact info so what's happening
next is is there's got them in Supergirl on
Monday I'm probably going to post my Gotham
video first and if you didn't see the last
Supergirl video up as opposed like a trailer
video for episode two I said that I'm probably
going to be doing Supergirl videos on Thursdays
so the be a little bit different for my typical
top five WTF videos that I do for episodes
but it just stay tuned for the next Supergirl
video I post it'll completely explain everything
to be confused about when videos are posting
just follow me on twitter and Facebook that's
usually where I post updates ON just a heads
up normally game of thrones will be posting
on Sundays I'm just moving that to Monday
because everything's been backed up with me
moving to a new apartment this week so no
worries still game of thrones coming so there
is new walking dead tonight white as way for
that and everything else to post you can click
here for my flash episode five sailor bunch
of zoom onto Dr. light and here for the Supergirl
trailer video I talked about think you so
much for watching everybody high five and
I'll see you guys tonight!